You've just worked with the question class and now its time to form a Subclass.
We've all seen these multiple choice questions, as a question and there're
multiple choices hence the name. By the way, if you ever want to know what's
the original name of the Java language, it was Oak, which was a name that was
so dull and boring that they changed it. Now, of course, one could put this
entire text here into a question class and set the answer to this string three.
But that too would be dull and boring. It would be better to have a class that
specifically deals with multiple-choice questions. So that we could declare an
object, somewhat like this. We make a Choice Question, that's what I'm calling
this class. We still need to set the text of course, but then for the choices I
want to be able to call a method that I call addChoice that adds the particular
choice and then specifies whether it's false or true. When I formed the Choice
Question class, I didn't want to start from scratch. I want to inherit as much
as possible from the question class that's already written. Let's see how to do
that. I'll define the ChoiceQuestion class and then I specify that it extends
the question class, that's the Java keyword for denoting that ChoiseQuestion
should become a subclass of question. Into the body of the subclass, I put in
any new methods that are present in the subclass but not the super class. Such
as the Add Choice Method. You also put in the implementations of any methods
that needed to change in the sub class. For example, we'll need to change the
display method, since displaying a choice question must also display the
choices. And finally, you of course need to add any instance variables that the
choice question class needs to do its job. In our case, that would be the list
of the choices. The key point is what you don't put in here. When you define a
subclass, you never include any of the methods from the superclass that work
just fine. For example, the set text method will work fine, and we can simply
inherit it from the superclass. Also, you don't want to include any fields from
the superclass. You get those automatically, and if you were to include them
again, you'd get 'em twice, which is not good. The point is that, what you put
inside here is the difference from the superclass. Everything that the subclass
has, that the superclass doesn't have at all or that it doesn't have in the
same way. Let's have a closer look at exactly how that works for question and
choice question. Here is our question class, here is the choice question class.
Now have a close look and tell me, which methods does the choice question class
inherit? Just give me the names of all those methods that choice question
doesn't redefine, that it simply picks up from question. Which methods does
choice question overrides? That is which method does choice question need to
redefine because the one's from question are not satisfactory. And finally,
which method or methods does choice question add that weren't present in the
question class in the first place? Just give me the names of the methods, all
together there are 5 of them.